China has also shut down the Beijing
LGBT Center the last large
LGBT organization in the country China
and Russia are not having this I really
think the U.S should take notes
especially all of those places that are
performing gender reassignment surgeries
on children any school that has ever
pushed any gay sex any gay propaganda
lgbtq propaganda in schools there should
be harsh prison sentences for any school
that has allowed that into their
institution we need to start fighting
back against this stuff it is absolute
that we have an entire month
dedicated to gay people that make up a
very small percentage of the population